Jane Eyre was a young orphan being raised by Mrs. Reed.
Mrs. Reed was her cruel, wealthy aunt.
She sent away Jane to Lowood School.
A typhus epidemic went through Lowood and Jane's friend, Helen Burns, died.
After completing school, she taught at Lowood for two years.
Afterwards, she worked at Thornfield manor and tutored a lively French girl named Adele.
Her boss was Rochester and Jane soon fell in love with him.
Rochester proposed to Jane...
...but, on their wedding day, she learned that he was already married.
Rochester explained that his wife went mad.
He had kept her hidden at his house for many years.
In distress, Jane fled Thornfield.
Penniless and hungry, Jane was forced to sleep outdoors and beg for food.
Three siblings took Jane into their home.
There she discovered that the siblings were her cousins...
...and that she had inherited a large sum of money.
Jane realized that she still loves Rochester and went back to Thornfield.
But the Thornfield manor was burned to the ground by a fire.
Rochester lost his eyesight and one of his hands,...
...and his wife was killed in the fire.
Rochester and Jane rebuilt their relationship and soon married.